MICHAEL PICCUIRRO: Hi, my name
is Michael Piccuirro.
I'm a director of product
and innovation.
I work at R/GA, which is a
large interactive agency.
R/GA builds large interactive
experiences for their clients.
We chose Google Cloud Platform
because it is a great tool
that allows us to build
solutions very quickly and
deploy them somewhere that can
scale to whatever we need.
Sometimes we're working with
client IT departments, but
that can cause some problems.
Especially, since we're not
technically employees,
sometimes we don't have the
ability to go into their
networks and deploy stuff.
The Cloud Platform tools are
very helpful in allowing us to
build things very quickly.
A lot of times, people are
very accustomed to having
their own private servers and
private infrastructures, and
there's a lot of fear about
producing something that's
running in an environment
that's
essentially out of your control.
So I would just say, try
to get over that fear.
Just run through the examples.
Do some test applications.
Get it out there.
Get very comfortable with the
platform, and you'll find that
it's a lot easier and a lot more
scalable than any kind of
private infrastructure.
My absolute favorite feature is
the ability to version and
rollback deployments
that you do.
Because it allows you
to push stuff out.
If it's not right or if there's
a problem, you can,
click of a button, rollback to
the way it was, and go back to
working on your problem, and
pick it up on Monday morning.
Where I see our company going is
that we'll be able to build
bigger, better experiences for
our clients in a lot shorter
amount of time than we
previously were able to.
Things that we would have
normally taken years to build,
we'll be able to produce in
weeks or months, and tools
like Cloud Platform will
be very helpful in
making that a reality.